[Música]
día tras día los hermanos gemelos hun y
huku corrían de un lado a otro jugando a
la pelota un día su vigoroso juego
perturbó a los Dioses del inframundo
quienes desafiaron a los gemelos a un
partido cuando los hermanos llegaron los
dioses los atraparon y los mataron
colgando la cabeza de jun de un árbol
como un
trofeo el árbol pronto produjo muchos
frutos lo que llamó la atención de una
de las hijas de los dioses cuando ella
agarró un fruto el cráneo de jun escupió
en su mano y la
embarazó huyendo de la ira de su padre
se refugió con su suegra y dio a luz a
gemelos
junajpu e
ixbalanque la segunda generación de
gemelos descubrió el juego de pelota de
su padre que su abuela había escondido y
empezaron a
jugar muy pronto los mensajeros del
inframundo llegaron para emitir otro
desafío aún sabiendo lo que les había
pasado a sus padres los gemelos
respondieron a la llamada atravesando
cavernas profundas y cruzando Ríos
llenos de escorpiones sangre y pus hasta
que llegaron a la gran ciudad donde los
Dioses del inframundo controlaban cada
aspecto de la naturaleza y les causaban
sufrimiento a los
humanos los gemelos siguieron buscando a
los dioses que los habían desafiado los
dioses se escondieron entre estatuas
para confundir a sus invitados pero los
hermanos enviaron a un mosquito por
adelantado cuando picaba a las estatuas
los dioses gritaban
revelándose obligaron a los gemelos a
pasar la noche en la casa de las
tinieblas les dieron una antorcha que
debían encender sin fuego o
morirían mientras oscurecía los
inteligentes hermanos adornaron la
antorcha con plum de guacamayo rojo y
luciérnagas por la mañana los dioses se
sorprendieron al ver la antorcha
encendida sin
fuego insistieron en jugar con su propia
pelota los gemelos estuvieron de acuerdo
pero los dioses habían escondido un arma
dentro de la pelota que los persiguió
por la cancha tratando de matarlos los
gemelos sobrevivieron a esa primera
ronda Pero a estas alturas estaban
seguros de que este no sería un partido
normalar muchas más rondas y cada vez
los gemelos no hacían más que empatar
haciendo que se enfrentaran a cualquier
prueba sobrenatural que los dioses
escogieran para ellos antes de retomar
el juego sobrevivieron a la casa del
frío encendiendo un fuego y a la casa de
Los Jaguares alimentando a las bestias
con huesos pero en la casa de los
murciélagos uno le arrancó la cabeza a
hunp seguros de que ahora tenían la
ventaja los dioses pidieron otra ronda
del juego de la pelota exhibiendo la
cabeza de junajpu en la cancha el
inteligente ixbalanque llamó a los
animales una tortuga le trajo un
chilacayote y él lo talló a semejanza de
una
cabeza mientras los dioses corrían tras
la pelota él la intercambió con la
cabeza con la cabeza de hunahpu sobre su
cuerpo los gemelos jugaron mejor que
nunca finalmente ganaron el juego y
golpearon la calabaza colgante por lo
que se hizo añicos en el suelo los gemos
sabían que sus anfitriones no serían
buenos
perdedores para protegerse reclutaron a
un par de
espectadores efectivamente los dioses
cocinaron a los hermanos en un horno
pero los espectadores se aseguraron de
que sus restos fueran arrojados al río
que les devolvió la vida los gemelos se
presentaron ante los dioses disfrazados
de dos niños desaliñados y comenzaron a
bailar y a hacer
Milagros para su último truco xbalanque
fingió matar a hunahpu y luego lo
resucitó los dioses estaban tan
encantados que exigieron que se les
hiciera el mismo truco a un disfrazados
Los Hermanos estaban encantados de
complacerlos y comenzaron a matar a los
dioses uno por
uno cuando los dioses supervivientes se
dieron cuenta de quiénes eran ellos y de
que no habría ninguna resurrección
suplicaron Piedad y los gemelos los
maldijeron de ahora en adelante los
dioses no tendrían sacrificios ni poder
alguno sobre el mundo de la superficie
sus días aterrorizando a los humanos se
habían
acabado quieres seguir Aprendiendo
suscríbete a nuestro canal y mantén la
curiosidad